in our chain Northern Indonesia hundreds
of rohingya refugees have found shelter
in a government building close to the
coast safe at last after a dangerous
journey to get to Southeast Asia
on the boat we didn't have food water or
medicine we felt like we were dead
already and I heard that a child died on
the boat
Faisal says he left Bangladesh after
around six years in a crowded and
impoverished Camp others say they
boarded the boat thinking of their
children
we wanted to go to Malaysia but our boat
ran out of gas and we ended up in
Indonesia we were searching for a place
where we could find peace and give our
children education
many told Al Jazeera about the joy they
felt when their feet touched the ground
for the first time in almost a month
we are very grateful to the Indonesian
government and people for providing us
with medical treatment and a safe place
to stay
Indonesia hosts around 13 000 refugees
they don't have any rights to employment
residency or citizenship here
we don't want to stay here we want to
leave this place our plan is to live
freely and to attain nationality
according to the international
organization for migration more than 3
000 rohingya arrived in the region in
2022 an increase of almost 300 percent
on the previous year this year several
boats with hundreds of rohingya people
have arrived in Indonesia Jakarta has
called on Southeast Asian countries to
work together to address the crisis
including cooperation on rescues at sea
human rights groups say Indonesia must
lead the regional block to a solution
should not just discuss this as a at the
Diplomatic level but more importantly
taking more concrete steps to make sure
that the root cause is being addressed
Indonesia as a chair has to discuss this
with all asean government in the region
to
Define a solution on how to best
approach the the flux of refugee from
from Myanmar for now this group says
they are happy the worst is over for
them now they are wondering what comes
next we want to laugh and live together
in peace
where we can be happy
after years of trauma and uncertainty
shamshida says she's unsure whether such
a place exists Jessica Washington Al
Jazeera check out her